je vais tout vous montrer je vais tout
vous dire sur les vrais rapports entre
les chroniqueurs déjà il ya une belle
solidarité
regardez valérie bénaïm quand un de ses
camarades se casse la gueule à côté
d'elle enfin c'est remarquable parce
qu'en fait elle fait rien non plus au
mieux les dénoncer aux manettes pas mais
je suis pas là dedans bonjour à tous
j'ai regardé regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des clips dix familles à l'ordre et
c'est l'anniversaire de l'un de nous et
bata c'est la fête très serré mais il y
en a une autre qui fêtait son
anniversaire
c'est éric camous leeuw a dit vous
verrez que vous mettiez votre 34 ans
ouais parce que y'a pas un mec de
l'équipe c'est bien vous d'aller voter
eric assez particulier on les aime bien
amoché mena on la comprend pas toujours
mais parfois par dans des explications
binaire on n'arrive pas à suivre
là vous allez voir sans raison
particulière et nous parler de sa soirée
dans un escape game
regardez là tu corriges membres et basse
mais c'est parce qu'il était dur on en
passe tout le monde est magique mais mon
préféré c'est gilles verdez lui il est
carrément panique j'ai fini cette
dernière c'est génial ça me fait penser
à ça c'est à dire qu'on tend vers la
culture de jury comprend pas fait rire
il faut que je vous enverrai à cirer le
cintre de fou vous êtes dans une pièce
vous avez des tumeurs mais absolument
pas manquer si vous avez 60 minutes
[Applaudissements]
il cherche du soutien le gardien du
soutien de mes jambes me dit quelque
chose il est temps at on même c'est bon
là qu'on l'ait mal à l'aise singularité
comme vous tous ici d'ailleurs voilà
vous avez tous une singularité
d'autant plus que d'autres voilà oui
mais c'est normal il faut s'habituer
titi et jean-michel par exemple a fait
longtemps qu'ils se reconnaissent donc
ils sont très complices est-ce que trop
non mais franchement je regardais un
petit peu dans le rétroviseur ils ont
beaucoup évolué depuis le début de
touche pas à mon poste là pour un débat
on avait distribué des pancartes avec
des têtes de présentateurs de jt
bonjour
les b
[Musique]
ouais quand même et ça va sinon d'aiton
savoie les temps quand on voit ça on
aimerait bien que jean-michel repartent
couvrir un conflit quand même la
personne et brion la meilleure
intervention de jean michel du mois
complet a fallu ce bonus malus palus
après ils s'étonnent que je montre voilà
l âge expliquant même cyril parler latin
et demander les mots que les
chroniqueurs connaissez ce qui nous a
mené à cette belle réflexion de notre
champion
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
stéphane bern présenté par jean-michel
baer a baissé mes secrets d'histoire pas
parce qu'on a perdu et déjà possible
mais touche pas pourquoi c'est aussi un
esprit de cohésion
je passe qui vous souvenez de l'émission
spéciale koh lanta et ben lors de cette
édition il y avait deux équipes
aouita nas lra sera presse et à la pause
le producteur nourdine était venu voir
chaque équipe pour le demander de
trouver un cri de guerre s'est pas
désisté de volonté ce brillant
brainstore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce pack est plus fort à la fin d'année
ont noué les horizons d'avoir le bonheur
expansif parce que une minute plus tard
c'est ce qui l'aurait dans la série on
est on est les retraits ou non vous êtes
l'état lâche alors cela dans notre salut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
elodie et l'autre qui me ce démon qui
n'ont jamais joué que moi je les vois
dépité je sais pas pourquoi moi je dis
voilà j'en reviens à ma place tranquille
séries lourdes je me dis mon nom je leur
dis non et en fait à oui vous avez bien
possible est très déçu mais ce côté là
bon après je vous refais pas toutes les
missions mais à un moment l'état nas ont
dû éliminer des races rares et bas comme
c'est le prime de la vérité je dois le
dire ci et n'aura été sauvée c'est grâce
à mathieu conseil de koh lanta une
tension c'est le voyage en garde la même
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
y'a bien d'ailleurs mais doit voir
toutes les façons on garde la neige ce
n'est pas ce qui va avoir des faits pour
mieux je suis juste cette scène ce que
je veux dire vous défendez pas d'armé et
n'aura il vous a sauvé parce qu'il vous
aime on s'en fout de la taille des gens
pourtant c'est le talent mais il a
raison il dit la raison mathieu aime
beaucoup et n'aura à rien alors quand il
s'agit de définir notre petit but breton
à celui qui en parle le mieux est basse
et mathieu à la si on peut le dire tu es
débordante de conneries mais ça valait
donc ona non mais moi il me colle pas ce
que j'ai fait un nom quand même un faux
pas les miens
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous l'adorez impôts il adore mais c'est
un pote c'est un poteau avec des nichons
bon ça c'était l'époque où mathieu
n'était pas encore capricieux et oui ça
essayez là où on disait de ce soir ah
bah non c'est fini
s'il n'a pas sa place il boude regardez
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nouveau
et c'est nouveau ce petit effet il faut
savoir la place de mathieu c'est là à
côté de valérie bénaïm et ça pour
valérie ses plus gros coup dur parce que
mathieu comment dire il est gentil il
comprend tout très vite mais il faut lui
expliquer longtemps
par exemple depuis le début de l'année
il est persuadé que valérie et arabes
maroc obligatoirement elle a dû investir
dans un restaurant de couscous pour lui
c'est comme est une idée en tête d'aller
voir au bout d'un moment même si c'est
très difficile de le faire sortir de ses
gonds on sent que valérie on a vraiment
ras le bol
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jamal
c'est
[Musique]
la conclusion c'est vrai même du coup
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
voilà pour que vous sachiez merguez
boulette tout ça c'est là là ça n'a rien
à voir c'est hachis parmentier voilà toi
cauvin baila tout ça d'accord vous avez
vous à contrôler deux d'accord vous êtes
entre la merguez et le pois chiche
alors ça prouve à mon gsm et